i've been waiting to talk to you oh yeah
have you in person yeah we've texted
back and forth since friday afternoon
but the moment that your guy
the guy whose initials appear on your
leg oh jesus goes all in right all in
you may not have unique knowledge but
it's kind of like the harry potter scar
i mean it throbs i'm not sure when
something like this happens
maybe just kind of the electricity in
the air makes its way into your leg and
up to your brain and you can help us
understand these things but the all-in
move yeah i mean when you least expect
it expect it good lord the 49ers jumping
from 12
to three
to get
presumably not caleb farley not the
tackle from oregon not anybody but
a quarterback
moving all that way up and what they
will eventually do folks and i can't
believe there's a debate over this
eventually they will use three
first-round picks and a third round pick
to get a quarterback at a time when
we've been hearing three first-round
picks is the starting price for russell
wilson and deshaun watson before two
weeks ago three first-round picks and a
third-round pick will be devoted to a
quarterback that is amazing to me that
the 49ers have someone or multiple
someone's they love enough chris to make
that kind of a jump i mean big time move
uh that's that's all i could say i was
shocked you know when it came to friday
morning i was just like whoa i mean i
just
that that's you don't expect that kind
of move
that far out in the draft i guess is
what i was a little surprised by right i
think that's the first thing went well
man we're five weeks away still wow okay
we're making these kind of moves right
now and then you know you sit there and
you think about the 49ers yeah of course
you know kyle shanahan's my friend it
doesn't mean i know every little thing
that goes on in his organization nor
does he tell me nor does he that implies
you know that that implies you know a
lot of people don't know every little
thing well i don't you said friday
morning when you said friday morning i
thought hey this guy had a heads up
because it didn't break until friday
afternoon so you knew what was going on
that's what it tells me well no i will
say this i know friday morning i started
to hear from a few people in the nfl
that it was going down i did late friday
morning right so i had to win right
thanks for telling me thanks for telling
me that okay i gotta get the guy chased
the story well i i had win that there
was a big trade going to go down that
that's really what i had heard and i was
going to the dmv anyways so either way
you're not getting a text in that
situation but
i mean i think the big thing is with
shanahan more than anything you know
taking fate into his own hand destiny
into his own hands that's the first
thing i think that's the first thing of
where you got to start there he's at
number 12. you know yes i would think
he's moving up to number three to get a
quarterback there's no doubt you don't
move up to number three unless you're
trying to get a quarterback 12 we talked
about it a lot you talk about that area
of the draft in the first round it's
iffy that's iffy territory whether
you're gonna get the quarterback you
like
in that situation there's too many ifs
ands and butts and candies and nuts as
far as who might draft a quarterback in
front of you who possibly could trade up
in front of you to then snag a
quarterback they like so i think
shanahan being aggressive and that he is
or in the way that he is
he said the hell with that i'm gonna
move up and take fate into my own hands
and now i know
i'm gonna get one of the quarterbacks
that i like or see fit to see fit in my
offense
how much of this do you think
is an attempt
to rectify the mistake that was made
four years ago when he was so locked on
to the presumed likelihood in his mind
he was going to sign kirk cousins in
2018 as a free agent he didn't evaluate
the quarterbacks in the draft class that
year whiffed on patrick mahomes whiffed
onto sean watson went with a defensive
lineman at number three right do you
think and that's part of the irony here
again i never know if the word's being
used properly but he had number three
in 2017 after trading down a spot with
the bears now he moves up to number
three clearly intent on taking a
quarterback do you think he's trying to
make up for the mistake that was made in
2017. well i think that he's probably
had enough and just going to go wait i'm
going to get the guy i want in here and
and that's the bottom line right i mean
yes
you know i knew all those things the
time i think there was a real thinking
of hey i'm going to get kirk cousins at
some point you know
uh in this first year two years whatever
i'm in whenever that happens in san
francisco you know then there's a
history you know of you know those type
of quarterbacks and everything like that
as far as that fit the system and i
think that's why a lot of people think
it's mac jones as far as who the 49ers
got their eye on at number three but yes
who do you think it is well i think it's
mac jones i do you know i don't know
that but just knowing my friend knowing
his history knowing his school of
thought to make that type of move
that's the one that makes sense to me
and i think it's the one why
well i think it makes sense to him
one because i think after trevor
lawrence and zach wilson and you know i
think those are the top two guys in the
draft zach wilson being number one you
know
he's the most nfl ready right now and i
would say really zach wilson and mac
jones to me are more nfl ready as far as
reading nfl defenses and being able to
do you know nfl offense type of stuff
you know trevor lawrence was in a little
bit of more of a ecology offense i'm not
trying to disrespect him by that but i
think within that mac jones is nfl ready
right now and i think that's the kind of
guy you trade up to to number three to
get you don't trade up to a trey lance
of a well
we he's got great talent but we're not
sure you know it's a little bit of a
gamble you know we there there are some
things that we got to help him out with
and grow his technique and figure those
type of things out and i think that goes
with justin fields too that it's a
little bit more of a project so i don't
think you trade up to a number three
pick for that kind of guy i think you
trade up for a number three pick where
you go no
i kind of think this guy if i had to
could start and play this year ready to
go week one and that to me smells mac
jones because i expect zach wilson and
trevor lawrence to be gone of course
and let's make sure we are clear on this
because again i'm astounded by the fact
that it's even a debate it shouldn't be
this falls into what color is the sky
type of territory in my mind every time
you use a first round pick you are
trading that pick for the player you
select because you could have done other
things with that first round pick
specifically you could have like the
steelers did in 2019 trade your 2020
first round pick for what minka
fitzpatrick right so
that that pick is an asset that
eventually is exchanged you exchange
your first round pick for a player every
first round pick that's used is traded
for a player so when you give up the
12th overall pick and two future first
round picks and a third round pick to
move to number three and eventually
exercise that pick for a player you
necessarily have traded
three first-round picks and a third
round pick
for
one player you better love that player
before you give up that much for that
player would that have been enough to
get to sean watson pre-lawsuits three
ones and a three i don't know but we
were talking about three ones as a
starting point for watson three ones as
a starting point for russell wilson
three ones and a three
to get an unproven player who may never
become anything in the nfl yeah i posted
last night all first-round quarterbacks
since the the
dawn of the super bowl era and it's
amazing when you look at the names there
there are so many of oh i forgot about
that guy oh my god that guy stunk oh
this guy was never any good there are so
many guys it's a roll of the dice to
love a guy enough to give up three ones
and a two
that leads to the point you made this
isn't somebody who's a project this
isn't jordan love i don't think who's
gonna sit and sit and develop and sit
right especially when there's likely
gonna be no off season program this year
at least not on field this is a guy
who's game ready which leads to the
other point chris yeah what happens to
jimmy garoppolo now that that's that's a
big question and and i don't know that
answer i i mean listen it can go two
ways you know i understand you know the
49ers
john lynch he came out and you know
still was some somewhat supportive of
jimmy garoppolo and that he could he
still can be our starter and made those
type of comments i don't think that's
crazy i don't you know not if you made
me bet i i would say that's not going to
happen
but you know either way
you could be sitting there going yes all
right hey whoever it is at three mac
jones whatever we whoever we get at
quarterback we'd like him to sit one
year maybe behind a guy that we know can
take our team to the super bowl and do
some special things when he's healthy
but i i i'm not gonna lie i just don't
see that happening i don't see that
happening i mean we got time before the
draft here we still got too many teams i
got some quarterback questions who's
going to be the guy we know there's some
teams out there that have some needs for
the position i just have a hard time
believing uh i think as you do with what
i read some of your articles on pro
football talk that the 49ers will keep
him i think when it all comes down to it
that yeah there will be a trade market
and they will try to deal with them and
i think that if it is mac jones what i
expected to be he'll be the guy because
of boom what we just talked about he's
game ready he's nfl ready right now and
he's a really really good fit for the
shanahan offense and scheme and how how
he wants to run his his team
chef he had the scoop on friday
afternoon and then he immediately began
to sell the idea that the 49ers are
keeping jimmy garoppolo for 2021 right
is that is that the price for having the
scoop wouldn't be the first time
something like that's happened and we
peel back the curtain all the time to
let folks know how the sausage gets made
my reaction to it was percy harvin yeah
2013 we have no intent to trade percy
harvin josh rosen two years ago remember
when the cardinals were holding the
first overall pick in the draft they had
no reason to play games with anyone
about anything they had a clear shot to
kyler murray cliff kingsbury quoted as
saying josh rosen is our guy dave
gettleman two years ago leading into the
off-season window that saw odell beckham
jr traded by the giants to the browns
gettleman says we didn't sign obj to
trade him my reaction is and my general
approach is when it comes to these kinds
of things believe no one believe
nothing and my understanding is both
shanahan and lynch are due to talk to
the media later today believe nothing
they say because there's a strategic
component to it sure this isn't a
question of whether or not people are
honest and truthful and you should trust
them if they're trying to sell you a car
this is about
whether or not it helps them and their
broader goals and objectives if they
wear on their sleeve what they truly
think about jimmy garoppolo because
chris they have to posture to try to
trade him at this point you got to get
value for your assets they don't want to
just cut him they want to get something
for him they're saying make people think
he's part of their plans and they need
to make people think that that they
should like him
more than they currently do i i mean
mike i don't disagree with anything
you're saying there you're right i mean
if they want to trade him you got to
make it make teams believe that hey
we're we're going to still keep this guy
you know i honestly i don't think it's
still
i still think that's a possibility or at
the very least at this moment right now
that
maybe they're not quite sure how they're
going to handle this situation and
you're right we're going to get some
questions answered by them and i i hope
people ask the right questions certainly
but don't you don't you need to have a
plan before you make that kind of a move
that's going to turn everything on its
head right in your organization don't
you have to have a plan for how you're
going to deal with jimmy g they admitted
last year they spoke to garoppolo when
they were evaluating the possibility of
adding tom brady in free agency do you
think garoppolo had any idea this was
coming or did he find out the same way
the rest of us did as a shocker on a
friday afternoon no morning if you have
inside information i'd be shocked well
yeah i'd be shocked um really if
garoppolo didn't have any clue about
this going down or anything like that
you know the one thing with shanahan man
you know we've talked about this before
he's pretty he is a really honest
football coach i don't think he's trying
to throw anything out this you know out
of left field onto his quarterback his
football players so listen again i don't
know but i would think contact was made
somewhere there so jimmy g's not reading
it on pro football talk or on social
media or something like that now is
there a plan to a degree yeah i'm sure
there is mike i'm sure i mean shanahan
and lynch aren't stupid i know my buddy
kyle he's always thinking about the
future and what to do and all those type
of things but you know having a plan and
being able to execute it exactly the way
you want you know i yes i i don't know
how that goes in my heart of hearts like
i've told you just because i know him
i've been friends with him i think we
have some of the same football logic
right yes i would think that this means
that they're going to be shopping jimmy
garoppolo and if it is if her a guy like
mac jones which i would be shocked and
again why why would i be shocked first
off jimmy garoppolo is that type of
player to a lesser extent in my opinion
all right matt ryan is a mac jones type
of player kirk cousins is a mac jones
type of player matt schaab is a mac
jones type of player now i want to say
this mac jones is more he throws a lot
of pick six well no i didn't know pac
mac jones through all those pick sixes
yeah well you you had me until you said
matt shaw oh well matt shobb you know
the one thing i'm just i'm just letting
you know about the kind of quarterback
shanahan likes and shaub you could say
what you want they were like a top
offense in football and a top five
offense in football i agree it's like
three years right somewhere there but
but my point is this mike is just that
i think shanahan looks at this and goes
wait i think mack jones is more talented
than
you know um kirk cousins coming out in
the draft i think he had matt ryan and
we saw he had them for two years and one
of those was a really special year where
they went to the super bowl and did mvp
type stuff and i think he's sitting
there going
i think this guy's just like that he's
talented like matt ryan and he could
dice you up with his arm and his brain
and his decision making and the
athleticism is enough for him to do the
boots and play actions for my offense
and if you give me a crack of more than
two years with a quarterback like that i
think he thinks i'm gonna win a super
bowl and i think that's ultimately
probably why he makes that type of
decision and i would like i said i will
be shocked i'll be shocked if it's not
mac jones at number three i really would
be and one of the things we've talked
about in recent weeks as it relates to
mac jones he doesn't really look the
part right think about the names you
just rattled off yeah right matt ryan
look the part does matt schaub look the
part does kirk cousins look the part i
mean they don't have that same kind of
a very unique thick midsection like mac
jones has and they don't look as
ungainly
and old school bobby lane joe cappish in
their
uniforms right but shanahan's gonna look
past that he's not gonna get caught up
in that no he's gonna look at what the
guy can do in his offense and chris gets
back to
what i was saying earlier if you think
enough about the guy yeah to give up
three ones and a three to get him right
are you going to park him on the
sideline for a year
like i'm with you man i'm with you i
don't either i'm just saying i don't
know the answer to that i don't know uh
but i would expect like yeah like we're
talking about
that
you know there there's teams out there
where we've heard in the quarterback
conversation yeah i would think that
jimmy garoppolo who knows does new
england revisit the situation with jimmy
garoppolo you know the carolina panthers
and the deshaun washington watson issue
we know that they like desean watson i
don't know jimmy garoppolo is available
now would you want him there i don't
know the denver broncos their team right
now we've heard comments about you know
they might bring in another quarterback
is jimmy garoppolo the type of guy
they'd bring in to compete with drew
locke so there is going to be options
out there i think to make a move here uh
or at least shop him to some teams that
that have some real needs of the
position
coincidentally we have a draft coming up
later in the program of the most likely
destinations for jimmy garoppolo in
2021 and
i
what you said something earlier that i
made a note of yeah okay when you were
explaining why kyle shanahan moved up to
number three you said he's probably had
enough right well if you've had enough
that that's why i can't reconcile moving
up to three yeah for a guy that you
clearly love
and then saying i'm sticking with my
other guy for one more year because i've
got a super bowl ready team if that if
that's how you feel
then you don't give up three ones and a
three
to go get
one guy now yeah i hear you if you feel
like you can get it done with who you
have
you don't do this i mean this is the way
the human brain works kyle shanahan went
to the lab and i suspect he said okay
trevor lawrence he's not going to be
there i'm not wasting my time zach
wilson maybe he'll be there i'm going to
do the full dive on him and then mac
jones justin fields trevor not trevor
lawrence uh trey lance kellen monde i'll
look at all these other guys and i'll
see how i feel
and you know we we've focused on mac
jones and you're convinced it's going to
be him
do you see a set of facts where it is
lance or fields at number three that
those are the guys that kyle's fallen in
love with it i mean
does it scare me a little bit yeah
because fields and lance have some big
time talent traits they they have some
elite ability there's no doubt about it
i think there's a lot of work there that
needs to be done for both football
players as you've heard me talk about
but
when i think of those two guys
and i think of shanahan i do go
wait well as maybe is he thinking about
doing some new age
quarterback baltimore ravens run offense
with with one of those two guys who are
special runners and gonna do that you
know for the first year or two of their
careers as he molds them into dropback
quarterbacks like has that thought
crossed my mind absolutely and i'm like
man maybe maybe that's what he's gonna
do
but i just have nothing in my history or
knowledge of my friend
or anything that i've seen him as far as
coaching offenses talking about
quarterbacks
i don't to make me think it's going to
go that way
you know we i know rg3 was there right
with washington but as you and i both
know too
that trade didn't really go down because
of the shanahan family that went down
because because of daniel snyder he made
that move happen that that was kind of
forced onto the shanahan family and then
they made that happen there as far as
mike and kyle you know i i would think
again
in that same draft with rg3 they drafted
a kirk cousins i would think that's the
type of guy he wants shanahan's the type
of quarterback or a coach who coaches
his quarterback to where
he's gonna go wait i've set up this
perfect play just listen to me here and
you read this guy just read this one guy
and i promise you you know either
a or b will be open and if you just put
your eyes on him with this formation
i've concocted i know what defense
they're gonna be in and now this guy has
to make a decision i've put him in a
bind if you can just be a quarterback
that can be smart listen to him and now
make the appropriate throw he feels like
he can just dice you up all day long
with his brain and his creativity and
now i got a quarterback who can take
advantage of all that you know he is
putting out there the information wise
and the plays that are there to be had
and that's where i just sit back and go
i think that's matt jones i just mac
jones is he's the he's the best i've
seen since i've been in this business as
far as reading defenses pulling the
trigger of the football without even
thinking
and making the appropriate throw it's
him and joe burrow been the two best
i've seen and that's why i just keep
coming back to that mike sorry for the
long time i'm glad you mentioned no
that's fine i'm glad you mentioned the
rg3 trade yeah that occurred to me in
the immediate aftermath of this that
that this is kyle's rg3 that the rg3
thing wasn't a shanahan move it was a
snyder move but it was three ones and a
two for rg3 this is three ones and a
three for whoever it may be
and there's there's a a
a beauty to that there's a poetry to
that nine years later that shanahan is
making the move that he and his dad
would have likely preferred daniel
snyder didn't make to go up and get rg3
as you've said before they were talking
to peyton manning when it came across
the crawl on tv or they got the text
message or whatever that they were
trading up
presumably to get rg3 unless the colts
had wanted rg3 then they would have had
andrew luck but th this is a bold move
it's a big move it's a significant move
and
i can't reconcile going all in
with keeping jimmy garoppolo especially
at 25 million see i think what's going
to happen is
eventually they're going to squeeze him
to take less
and that request may come at a time when
it's too late for him to get more
elsewhere as a free agent or when it's
too late for him to go elsewhere and
become properly ensconced in a new
offense you do it in august
mid-august late august and you say hey
you know this 25 million is going to
work we like what we have in this guy
he's checked all the boxes so far we
want to pay you 15. we want to pay you
12. we want to pay you something
dramatically less than 25. see if i'm
garoppolo
and i wrote about this right before the
show i hadn't thought about it from his
angle what's he thinking how's he
reacting to this yeah if i'm garoppolo
i'm telling don yee my agent to find out
right freaking now
when
are they going to come to me and say we
want you to take less are you paying me
25 or are you not going to pay me 25.
and and if he asks are you going to seek
a pay cut
any answer other than no means yeah
eventually we're going to i'd want to
bring that to a head right now because i
want to know if i'm going to be looking
for a job elsewhere and at what cost
that's going to be to the 25 million i
was supposed to make this year yeah
that's i mean i i hear you there there's
definitely uh
you know some interesting points you
bring up there
i mean if i'm jimmy garoppolo you just
put yourself in his shoes
yeah at this point of course mike i go
back to what you say i think you're
you're correct i just have a hard time
thinking yeah we've traded up to number
three
that it won't be that guy
who will
you know be the starting quarterback for
the 49ers with jimmy garoppolo i mean if
i'm jimmy garoppolo i'm telling donyi
like start start calling some teams
quietly and let's just you know
start working some back channel stuff to
see if there are teams that are
interested in me or anything like that
but i think at some point they're going
to have to have a real conversation with
the 49ers because i would think shanahan
and lynch at this point have told jimmy
garoppolo
hey
we've moved to number three
hey
we're moving to number three for a
quarterback and i i would have a hard
time thinking knowing kyle and knowing
really john that they wouldn't be honest
with their player that way uh and that's
where it'll be interesting mike and i'm
with you i have a hard time thinking it
won't be you know whoever they drafted
three i'm expecting mac jones to be the
starting quarterback
and and this isn't the same as garoppolo
coincidentally being taken with a second
round pick in 2014 which led a fire
under tom brady's ass that propelled him
to three more super bowl wins before he
left new england this isn't jordan love
being taken bottom of round one last
year this is we have drafted your
replacement this isn't just in case you
fall off a cliff this isn't you're
getting older and we need to be ready
for the transition this is hey jimmy
we've tried it
we paid you a lot of money right we
tried it you're not the guy long term i
mean that's the thing lost in all of
this talk about whether or not he gets
one more year at very best he's alex
smith in 2017. that's right exactly
right the the question is is it in his
best interest to take whatever he can
get to reestablish himself this year and
then leave on a high note and become a
free agent next year when they
inevitably cut him because you know
that's scary though mike that's scary to
me that's scary if i'm the 49ers too
because the 49ers are a good football
team and if jimmy g stays healthy right
and they go 13 and three or four you
know what i mean that that that that's
scary right so i if i'm advising my
buddy kyle shanahan or john lynch i'm
going now you need to
you got a good team you start him and
let him play you might never be able to
not you know take or take him out or
then you're going to have an issue the
next year when you try to make you know
whoever that quarterback is your starter
they're all going to go what we went to
the nfc championship game with jimmy
garoppolo we're going to have that whole
issue so that's really you know part of
this conversation as well
yeah i mean nothing good comes from
saying hey we're going to flip a coin
and hope this is a year he stays healthy
if he stays healthy he's good enough to
take us to a super bowl so then what do
you have you have a mess yes
you know yeah if you win the super bowl
hey that's great we won the super bowl
but moving forward what do you do at
that point and
regardless of the fact that he's missed
23 games over the past three years i go
back to
the game we were at i know you do
divisional round i hear you kyle freaked
out and went run run run for the balance
of the game against the vikings and then
stayed in bob greasy mode with jimmy g
run run run eight passes in the are you
kidding me eight passes in the nfc
championship game and then
all right then the super bowl it was
more of a normal quarterback quarterback
a chance to and he had a chance to win
it had a chance to win this emanuel
sanders many times so
i i just think and and hey you know what
i could be wrong wouldn't be the first
time i can't imagine
giving up what they're giving up to get
their next quarterback and then saying
we're keeping him in the closet for a
year while we take one more run with
jimmy g i can't reconcile it and this is
different from patrick mahomes yeah and
alex smith first of all
it was the tenth pick not the third pick
yeah and it happened when the tenth pick
was on the clock this is a move that's
occurring five weeks before the draft
sending a clear message to the world
we have a guy we love and we're going
all in now
to get him we're not screwing around
just a few days after the mac jones
throwing session at alabama we're not
screwing around this is our guy it's a
much stronger statement than mahomes was
and there's going to be a much greater
expectation and a much greater hype
level attached to this guy
than it was with mahomes with mahomes it
was kind of like a curiosity and well
we'll give andy reid the benefit of the
doubt well there's still a perennial
playoff team and right well okay it was
it was a lot of well okay let's see yeah
you don't have that here here you have a
clear all-in
move
to get a guy who's going to be the next
quarterback not for somebody who's been
around for 10 years but for somebody
that was supposed to be the future and
who clearly isn't i i i i agree with you
one listen we talked about rg3 already
and
shanahan was capable of devising an
offense around him and that was a guy
that was raw right and didn't know drop
back nfl pass offense type of stuff mac
jones is
that that's that's not going to be an
issue he's as well schooled as they come
as far as that's concerned as far as you
know coming out of college sarkeesian
and nick saban and all that so he's
gonna be ready to go from that aspect
the other thing too mike to what you
bring up with like the mahomes stuff and
all that as well
i mean this is like what
shot five or six across the bow of a
warning sign here for jimmy g just this
off season to basically be like hey
we've we've tried to trade for this guy
we tried to trade for this guy we tried
to trade for this guy i mean he's got to
be getting the picture here a little bit
there's no doubt about it you know and i
think the team goes along with it
because i'm matt casey in my ear he goes
you know what does this do to the locker
room yeah the locker room likes jimmy g
the locker room likes jimmy g there's no
doubt about that but at the same time
the locker room's smart enough to
realize wait our coach who's an
offensive genius
okay
doesn't seem to be happy with our
quarterback so he must be doing
something
other than
not being available and being hurt there
has to be something more there
that is not you know
being met on an accident oh
you know uh what do i want to say an xml
basis there
to where i think that that also is gonna
the players are gonna get their heads
wrapped around this too to go okay
obviously the organization's looking to
move on as much as we like jimmy g blah
blah blah blah these are just the facts
of the matter and we're gonna have to
buy into whoever it is at number three
that comes in here and and is the
starting quarterback
i'm looking at the history of alabama
quarterbacks taken in round one
joe namath richard todd right
and is it possible that the next one was
tua
tuatanga vialoa last year at five i
think i think so
and
mac jones this year if it's him at three
amazing they've doubled yeah it was
stabler in two drafts for the second
round he was the second second round
yeah
um so it was richard todd and joe namath
for the entire history of alabama
football until last year and now it's
two at five and quite possibly mac jones
at number three and this jimmy g point
look hey
players are loyal to their teammates
yeah
they're with them all the time what are
you going to say get rid of him i i you
you just you just deal with it the the
circumstances change
and you adjust and you adapt and any
professional football player knows
that's going to happen across the board
on the roster it's just a question of
when you're the one who was there and
now all of a sudden is gone but you
think george kittle is going to demand a
trade because they move on from jimmy
garoppolo no he'll show up wearing a
t-shirt with mac jones picture on it
right after a month or two that's just
the way it goes yeah yeah no you're
right exactly right and you know usually
a quarterback has a good way of being a
leader of the team no matter what the
situation is and kind of just you know
letting his presence be felt and and
wear off on the team in some sort of
fashion or way either way but you're
exactly right you know the team will
move on and then they're gonna you know
whoever it is at quarterback they're
gonna see him come in and see what he's
all about and they'll buy in from there
so uh we'll see where it goes but man
big time move by shanahan the 49ers and
uh i'm excited to see how it all plays
out here over the next month or so
a stunning move that underscores the
reality that you never know when the
next big story is going to happen in the
nfl you always have to have on your
radar screen the possibility that
something will occur that will
stun you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports